[Music]
a lot of people might think it's
surprising that somewhere such as dubai
in the middle of the middle east would
offer hockey
[Music]
but people want to come and play with us
they're
playing for the love of the game
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is mike friesen and team i play
on is the dubai mighty camels
to come to a place where you only can
play indoors and even then it sometimes
is too hot the air conditioning can't
keep up it's quite a bit different than
my experience back home that's for sure
i grew up in rural alberta canada so it
was basically in your blood to play
hockey
yeah like every kid in canada we all
dream to play pro someday and now in
dubai i'm
able to do that
[Music]
ehl stands for emirates hockey league
and it was
created just to get the best hockey
players in the uae into a competitive
league to build and develop their local
players
we have six teams in the league this
year
we've had players that have played pro
they've played high college level in the
states high college level university
level in canada we have players that
played pro in europe all different
levels
[Music]
in dubai we don't have a local team of
emiratis but we play against the locals
in abu dhabi and in lane
playing in dubai mall exposes it to a
lot more people
it really brings more people to the game
you know when you're in dubai mall and
you're playing and you're surrounded by
a thousand people who 60 of them
probably have never seen it before it's
it's a special feeling it's it's an
honor to be able to do that
[Music]
obviously i think it's the best sport in
the world
it's
great to see that you're making some
sort of contribution to expanding the
sport and promoting it in parts of the
world where
it's not natural to be played
[Music]
you